in metagenomics 2 we talked about the
analysis of 16s
amplicon sequencing data in the course
you will find
information about the sequencing
approaches and what are we trying to
study using the 16s amplified
hypervariable regions
as you go through the course you will
get an introduction about
the biology as well as the data side of
things
and eventually you'll be introduced to
the analysis of 16s ribosomal
rna amplicon data
the first practical exercise will be
based on a visual interface
here we will go into a demo of a 16s
ribosomal rna processing pipeline
based on the data to package the data2
package
is focused on making sure that the input
data
is high quality and removes
noise before the data is analyzed
however once the data is analyzed and
structured
the taxonomy is assigned using a
reference database
we turn to visualization and
interpretation of the data from a
biological standpoint
as you build the pipeline you will see
some of the outputs that are typically
produced
by both the data to itself resulting in
a biome file
of all of the process data and then goes
into filo seek
a filo seek package produces multiple
plots
based on three input data sets now if we
want to go
behind the scenes and see what it does
we have made a tutorial in r
that you can go through and run a
code in r using the code playground
to learn what each portion actually does
so first you need to install filoseq
installing filoc can be done
using bioconductor biosee manager
install file c
now we need to import the data and there
are three different data types
that we need to import first of all
we're going to use
the amplicon abundance table or the otu
abundance table
then we will look at the taxonomy table
which assigns a toxin
of a taxonomic classification for which
one of our
operational taxonomic units and finally
we're going to look at a supplementary
table
that explains which sample comes from
which group
in this case we have the abundance table
based on each one of our samples and
each one of the assigned otus
we have a classification for the
operational taxonomic units
and we'll choose the phylum as the
taxonomic
assignment and then here is the
here is the sample input so you can see
that we have three groups
acne preor priori
dermatitis and non-healthy
now we're going to define what are the
these inputs
remove the columns that we don't use so
that we end up with a
matrix of data that philosophy can
process now we have to transform as
input for philosophy so we have to
assign them to specific names
and start visualization there are
several
types of visualizations that phylosec
can do bar charts
nmds or other types of dimensionality
reduction like principal coordinate
analysis
and then we can draw our plots and add
different types of annotation for the
plot itself
for example here you can see that we've
assigned
a bar plot based on ordination
and have a bar plot of composition
for all the different types of phyla
that we have
this is the output based on alpha
diversity
channel 1 or shannon and non-metric
multi-dimensional scaling ordination
for each one of our categories you can
see
adult acne none and perioral
dermatitis
now let's take a look at the code itself
so in the code playground what you will
have is
a full script that runs on the cloud
to perform all of this analysis let's
just click run
and see what it does i can edit the code
and what you will see is that the code
itself contains
all of the different types of results
but i just need to select which one
do i actually want to do do i actually
want to visualize
for example the first visualization is
going to be
samples and taxa nmds
or multi-dimensional scaling
of our samples and of all of the
different types so let's change that
instead of plotting ordination
we can look at
uh for example the ordination plot
now since i modified the script my
answer is going to be incorrect but you
can see that the plot now
is the ordination plot for all of the
samples colored by group
all of these different outputs are
actually explained in the metagenomics 2
course
so when you go into the study you will
see
a step-by-step guide as well as an
explanation
of what is it that we're actually
getting as an output
and what do these different types of
methods mean
so i welcome you to try this little
tutorial about metagenomic sequence
analysis
using the 16s amplicon data